Talent and power are hard to assess. Is a vampire
really stronger than a werewolf? Are all
angels stronger than all demons? Here's
a look at the most powerful villains on
Supernatural, from strong to strongest.
No matter who Alastair is currently
possessing, he's always one of the most
powerful demons. Hell's Grand Torturer answers
to few, save high-ranking demons like Lilith.
He's tasked with torturing Dean for about four
months in Earth time in order to free Lucifer
from his God-built cage. Although
Dean is a human, and Alastair has
home court advantage in Hell, the thought of
any entity having the ability to hold Dean
down for that long further proves
that Alastair isn't a normal demon.
His biggest claim to fame is playing
a role in triggering the apocalypse.
Even so, he's no match for Sam wielding
the full force of his psychic abilities.
After pinning Alastair to the wall,
interrogating him about Lilith's plans,
and discovering his lack of knowledge, Sam
kills him. So goes one of Hell's absolute
nastiest creatures — and one of
Supernatural's most memorable villains.
Azazel isn't the most powerful villain of all
time, but the yellow-eyed demon is basically the
reason John Winchester became a hunter, and
the reason he would go on to train his sons
in the family business. Azazel murders Sam and
Dean's mother in Supernatural's pilot episode,
launching the Winchesters' long, complex journeys
as hunters of all that goes bump in the night.
He's basically the reason for the entire show.
As a Prince of Hell, one of the first
generation of demons created by Lucifer,
he's already no average bad guy. Salt
and holy water have nothing on him — the
Winchesters need a relic to take down Azazel.
Enter the Colt, a revolver that could kill
virtually anything. On the verge of elimination,
Dean shoots Azazel with the Colt and it works
like a charm. He isn't quite that easy to get
rid of, however: He continues to haunt the show
long past his demise. A Prince
of Hell casts a very long shadow.
Metatron is an angel and the Scribe of God —
the only Scribe to ever have existed, in fact.
Eons ago, he was responsible
for transcribing God's word,
gaining universe-shaping information in the
process. He left Heaven to hide among humans,
for fear of what the Archangels might do
to him in pursuit of that information.
Metatron is the creator of the Angel
tablet, which grants immense power to
those in contact with it — power he eventually
exploits to expel all angels from Heaven.
While this makes Metatron unimaginably powerful,
his rule is short-lived, and he ends up locked in
Heaven's dungeon for his crimes. Even though he's
eventually imploded into nothingness by Amara,
he still remains an unforgettable character.
The Alpha Vampire is the first vampire, and
therefore the paragon of all vampires. He knows
of the ancient leviathans and claims to remember
"the continental divide," which gives the audience
an idea of how old and powerful he is. This is a
creature who has survived for millions of years as
"the thing in the dark" — it would be an
understatement to say he's not to be trifled with.
It can be argued that the Alpha
Vampire isn't truly villainous,
as he mostly just tries to live his
best life as a unique creature. But,
at the same time, he did create vampires,
who have killed countless people. In the end,
he falls to the legendary Colt, slayer
of entities otherwise invulnerable.
Abaddon, a Knight of Hell, took down the
original Men of Letters single-handedly.
She's the worst kind of villain, at least from
the Winchesters' perspective: massively powerful,
and absolutely desperate for control. Trained by
the biblical Cain, Abaddon is an ancient threat,
well-accustomed to blood and mayhem.
There is no one she won't possess,
slaughter, or maim in order to get what she wants.
After time-traveling to the present day,
she decides to pursue her biggest plan yet:
become the Queen of Hell. Like so many baddies,
she wants to rule the world through vast armies,
reserves of power, and iron law. Too bad
she comes across Sam and Dean Winchester.
Dean, empowered by the Mark of Cain,
eventually kills Abaddon with the First Blade,
a relic once described as "the most
dangerous weapon on the planet."
Lilith is the first demon Lucifer ever created,
and the highest-ranking demon, second only to
Lucifer himself. She's also the final seal of
the 66 that, when broken, frees Lucifer from
his cage. Even her death furthers a malicious
agenda. How's that for a commitment to evil?
Lilith's villainous resumé is long. She commands
a demon army, murders Dean with a hellhound, and
tortures countless humans. Although she arranges
for Sam to kill her, breaking the 66th seal,
she's eventually resurrected by God to retrieve
the Equalizer, a gun created by God that can
kill anything. She destroys the gun and delivers
some truly terrible news: God's endgame is for Sam
and Dean to kill each other. She's effortlessly
killed by the Archangel Michael not long after. A
short resurrection, but one that managed to shake
the foundations of the Supernatural universe.
Rowena is arguably the most powerful
witch in the Supernatural universe,
and really, not all that much of a bad
guy. She often helps Sam and Dean out,
sacrifices herself heroically, and even leaves
her magical possessions to Sam after her demise.
All this aside, however, she's season 10's
Big Bad : power-hungry, in possession of
undeniably dark magic, and willing
to do anything to benefit herself.
What makes Rowena so powerful? She's unstoppably
clever and thinks ten steps ahead of everyone
else. For example, when Lucifer kills her,
she manages to come back to life thanks to
resurrection spells she'd prepared in advance.
A later death is orchestrated to drag the damned
souls and demons, freed by God, back to Hell.
However, it's later revealed that she goes
on to become the Queen of Hell, so really,
she's not doing too badly in the afterlife.
Crowley's resume is riddled with
good and evil, making him more
of an antihero than a true out-and-out
bad guy. That said, Crowley is a demon:
He's power-hungry, puts himself before all others,
and is generally predisposed towards nastiness.
There are more powerful beings than
Crowley, but he's uniquely gifted.
Son of Rowena, he uses his smarts to outwit
other beings, which allows him to survive
and outlive more capable demons. And in the
real world, it also doesn't hurt that he's a
fan favorite — that's the sort of armor that
tends to keep a character healthy for years,
no matter what kinds of shenanigans
they get themselves involved in.
"I don't read Chinese"
"Talk about the dumbing down of America"
Though he's been everything from a human
to the King of Hell, Crowley is a demon
through and through. However, his final act is
heroic: He kills himself with an angelic blade
to seal Lucifer in an alternate dimension.
Light or dark, Crowley is truly one of a kind.
The Mother of All Monsters is named
Eve, and as her title suggests,
Eve created the very first versions
of each monster — the Alphas.
Eve is older than angels and Hell
itself. She loves her children,
despite their monstrous natures, and while she
cannot claim the highest body count on the show,
the amount of destruction and death her
children bring to the world is unfathomable.
While Eve is only around for one season,
she isn't a pushover. There's only one viable way
to kill her: phoenix ash. Once the heroes find it,
Dean consumes the ash in a shot of liquor,
then goads Eve into biting him, killing her.
Once upon a time, Dick Roman was
a billionaire businessman. Then,
he was murdered and replaced by the leader
of the leviathans, creatures so powerful
God created Purgatory to lock them away
forever. When a billionaire is combined
with God's first monsters, the result is one
of the most powerful beings on Supernatural.
Leviathan Dick Roman isn't only one
of the oldest beings of the series,
but he's also considered one of the most
powerful. Naturally, it takes a special weapon,
the Bone of A Righteous Mortal Washed in the
Three Bloods of Fallen, to take him down for
good. Without this weapon, the leviathans
likely would have taken over the world.
Despite the leviathans' legendary brutality,
Leviathan Dick Roman only hangs around for
a single season. He might be an ancient figure
of menace, but he goes up against Sam and Dean,
and eons-old baddies don't tend to fare
too well against the relentless brothers.
Raphael is an archangel, one of the most
powerful creatures in the Supernatural universe.
He can summon massive storms,
seems omniscient, and can blackout
the entire Eastern Seaboard with a blink. He's
ancient, unknowable, and altogether scary.
Although Raphael's time on Supernatural is
fairly short-lived, he's one of the most
powerful beings on the show. Few things can
actually kill an archangel: Other archangels,
God, Amara, or a handful of ancient weapons.
He's about as untouchable as a creature can
get — which makes it all the more impressive
that Castiel is able to take him down.
Even then, he can only do it when
supercharged by all the souls in Purgatory.
Like his brothers Lucifer, Raphael, and Gabriel,
Michael is an archangel. However, the Michael of
the alternate universe known as "Apocalypse World"
is easily one of the most powerful creations in
the series and one of the toughest villains Sam
and Dean are ever forced to stop. In his world,
one torn apart by the absence of the
Winchester brothers, he's a conqueror
of unimaginable power — he's often referred to
as the "Genghis Khan" of its ruined landscape.
As the eldest son of God, alternate Michael is
arguably even more powerful than Lucifer himself.
Some of the ingredients the Winchesters need
in the war against alternate Michael include
hunters, Castiel, Rowena, Jack, Gabriel, Lucifer,
and countless others. The battle is arduous,
but Michael is eventually defeated by
Jack, who exploits Michael's hubris.
The original Death, in theory, is in the
top three strongest beings on Supernatural.
Death has existed from the beginning of time
until his imminent demise. The original Death,
however, wasn't necessarily an
evil threat to the Winchesters.
The primordial entity was only
interested in keeping order.
Eventually, Dean kills Death with his own scythe,
and Billie, a reaper killed by Castiel, is
reincarnated and promoted as the new Death. Billie
assists the Winchesters in their endeavors and is
considered neutral for most of her time as Death.
She doesn't become a true villain until late in
the series. As the new Death, she inherits powers
and is among the most potent entities, and is
the only being that can read God's book. But the
Shadow drags her to a place of nothingness known
as the Empty, and her reign of terror ends. At
the height of her powers, though, Billie was one
of the strongest villains on Supernatural — even
if she wasn't considered an antagonist for long.
"This is the last time you'll
see me again. Until the end."
Lucifer is one of the most powerful villains
on Supernatural. A fallen archangel,
he's the original ruler of Hell and the
creator of demons; Lilith, the Princes of Hell,
the Knights of Hell, and all other manner
of dark creatures spring from his power.
Despite his abilities and maliciousness, Lucifer
is actually a pretty likable character. Sure,
the devil himself is oozing with darkness, but
this version of Lucifer is at
times laid-back and comical.
Had it not been for the Winchesters,
Lucifer stood a very real chance of
taking over the world. Eventually, he's put
down for good by alternate Michael and Dean.
His soul then dwells in the Empty, a peaceful
void where divine creatures sleep forever.
Because living things don't stay dead
on Supernatural for long, Lucifer is
resurrected by God — but then killed again, once
and for all, by Michael with an archangel blade.
The Darkness, also known as Amara, has
existed since before the beginning of time;
she's God's older sister. God had to create the
archangels to fight a war against her, which
they eventually won, and sealed
her away. She's the primordial
origin point of all existence, the
"nothingness" that reigned before
consciousness and creation. If either she or
God is destroyed, reality will cease to exist.
Amara is presumably stronger than God, yet
God can, with the help of others, stop her.
As a pillar of reality itself, she's the most
powerful force the Winchesters have ever faced.
Luckily for the Winchesters, The
Darkness leaves on her own terms.
But then, Amara completely rewrites history in the
final season, claiming that she and God were born
simultaneously. She allows God to absorb her, but
luckily, a juiced-up Jack absorbs God's powers
and becomes the new Almighty. Amara is also
absorbed by Jack, and they live in harmony.
From an aspiring writer to
the creator of the universe,
Chuck has a long and complicated history. Chuck
is seen as a good guy, or at least a mutual party
to the Winchesters, for a good portion of the
series. It's not until the end of Supernatural
when he's considered a full-on villain, and,
in fact, the Big Bad of the entire series.
For a long time, Amara was the perceived
strongest being. But Chuck being revealed
as the Big Bad of Supernatural counts for a
lot, as he's the final boss that stands in the
way of Dean and Sam's happiness. At the height
of his powers, Chuck absorbs Amara, making him
an unstoppable force, and the most powerful
villain ever. But alas, it's short-lived:
Jack strips Chuck of his powers, and the
creator of the universe is left to live
out the rest of his days as a mere mortal. The
story, to Chuck's dismay, continues without him.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Supernatural
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one!